optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking can I ask you a personal
question
now soon I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
99designs dot-com which is the largest
online marketplace for graphic design
with more than eight hundred and fifty
thousand registered designers from all
over the world who compete for your
business I've used them for years and
I've used them for some very big
projects like the book cover for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one New York Times best seller
translated into at least I would say 10
15 20 languages and I used 99 designs
because I needed results and I needed
them very quickly so here's how it works
you need a logo a website book cover
t-shirt car app whatever you put a
description on 99designs comm then
people submit designs and in a week or
less you have an original design that
you love or you get 100% of your money
back
so check out 99 designs com forward
slash Tim you can see some of the
projects that I've done personally and
you can also get a $99 upgrade for free
this highlights your project listing it
with a prominent background bumping it
to the top of the page and on average
this will attract close to 200 percent
more designs so check out 99 designs com
forward slash Tim and I think you'll
like what you see
hello ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls this is a very exhausted Tim
Ferriss and welcome to the Tim Ferriss
show so glad to have you you know I am
one tired saamne bit right now and I
couldn't be happier about it because
I've been flying around the country
doing various experiments and I had the
opportunity to go to Palm Beach Florida
to sit at the home of Tony Robbins and
ask him just about everything I've ever
wanted to ask him and this is a very
special interview for me this is the
interview the conversation I've wanted
to have for 15 years and now that I'm
back in SF gathering myself drinking
some what appears to be laughing coyote
tea I have no idea what's in it could be
all sorts of drugs psilocybin and I'm
thrilled to be putting this out there
for you because Tony is a fascinating
character for those of you who don't
know him he has consulted or advised
leaders including Nelson Mandela Mikhail
Gorbachev Margaret Thatcher
and Mother Teresa he's consulted members
of two royal families the US Congress US
Army US Marines three US presidents
including Clinton and other celebrity
clients would include names you know
like Serena Williams Andre Agassi Greg
Norman of course the golf legend
Leonardo DiCaprio and Oprah Winfrey who
calls him superhuman the stat that
always just sends my head spinning is
that Tony has developed and produced
five award-winning infomercials that's
of course how a lot of people came to
know of him and these infomercials have
continuously aired on average every 30
minutes 24 hours a day somewhere in
North America since check it out April
1989
it's just Tony TV out there 24/7
insanity this particular conversation is
broken into basically three parts the
first third of our very long
conversation in
helps me asking him the questions I've
always been dying to ask him ever since
I first was exposed to his material and
I explained a lot of the background
which is kind of hilarious when we get
started the second third and the third
third would and of course along the way
we talk about his daily routines the
types of questions that he asks
world-class performers and so on the
latter portions of this focus on what
tony has been researching and and really
teasing apart and analyzing for the last
well several decades but especially the
last four years and that is how do you
master the game of money why is there so
much financial illiteracy and how do you
stack the deck so that you can win
because there's a lot of hijinks and
there's a lot of nonsense out there how
do you actually invest what do you do
with your money and it's a huge topic
but he has interviewed and in fact
coached some of the most unbelievable
minds in the world of finance and
investing I couldn't believe the list
including people like Paul Tudor Jones
Ray Dalio
who's of course a a whiz in the world of
hedge funds and the list is unbelievable
Carl Icahn David Swensen who turned one
billion into I think twenty three
billion for Yale and some curious
characters like mark dr. doom Faber Sir
John Templeton Kyle Bass who became very
very famous for in effect predicting and
shorting the the subprime crisis or at
least he made his fortune one of his
fortunes in in seeing that through
through the looking-glass
these are these are the these the Navy
SEALs the the the the top of the top and
he has been able to ask them just about
everything that you would want to ask
them and a lot of what Tony's going to
say is controversial or counterintuitive
and no doubt you'll disagree with
some of what he says but I guarantee you
even if you don't care about investing
you think you don't care about investing
and by the way if you've decided not to
think about investing that is a decision
and investing I guarantee that if you
listen to this entire conversation which
I plan to listen to over and over and
it's it has a lot of information that
you will take away at least one or two
things from Tony that lead you to say
holy [ __ ] I've never looked at that
aspect of my life that way and it'll
turn things upside down and you will
walk away with a completely different
lens through which you can look at how
you're living how you're handling your
business and I think you will find
tremendous value from this single
interview so I will leave it at that you
know I don't want to oversell it I will
say that for me Tony can be an
intimidating guy just in sheer size he's
a big dude and he can actually pull my
entire face and now we have a photograph
of that that I'll share but I get into
that in the interview he's also very
seasoned pro and I have a lot of respect
for him so it takes me five or ten
minutes I'd say a let's just say 10
minutes to find my feet in this
interview when we hit our stride then
all sorts of gems come out and there's a
lot of good material in the beginning
but give it some time be patient listen
to this whole thing it is worth your
time so without further ado I think I've
had too much laughing coyote tea here's
Tony Robbins
alright ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show I have a very
exciting episode for you and a very
exciting guest mr. Tony Robbins Tony
thank you for having me in your home of
all places I'm glad to be home that's a
very much less to have you here grateful
that here as well and we have many
different topics I have many different
questions I'd love to delve into of
course I perhaps unbeknownst to a lot of
my fans have a long history with Tony
Robbins but not in person this is the
first and for those of you who don't
know some of the background when I first
graduated from school and moved to
Silicon Valley to chase the billions
that seemed just they were being handed
out in 99 I learned a 1999 they were in
a way and I was driving a hand-me-down
beat-up green minivan from my mom the
seats got stolen from inside or at least
the back so all my co-workers started
harassing me and calling it the molester
mobile and the job the company didn't
seem to be a long-term fit for me and
when I was on a road trip at one point I
bought personal power may have been
personal power too and I started
listening to it to and from work on my
commute which is terrible for those who
don't know the bear if you're on 101
rows between San Jose and SF it's
horrible and ultimately that was one of
the catalysts for me starting my first
company so simply touch that knowing all
that you've done that really touches
touches me completely cuz you're an
inspiring character to me oh not before
our work week is I don't looking for the
four hours sleep week at this stage I'd
like to be able to pull that one off but
but really I think the way you attack
subjects and that's what you do you
don't look at them you go after mastery
of them and the way you experiment and
the way you constantly dig underneath to
find the organizing principles I feel a
kinship with you we're in different
stages of life and things like that but
I have Norma's respect for you and I
don't feel that way about everybody I
like everybody
I don't respect everybody you deserve
the respect because you go deep most
people are really they're surface level
and what they do so excited to chat with
you and see what can come out this comes
thank you for sure and I have of course
a bunch of self-interested questions
that I think will also be interesting to
other folks hopefully but what's all
impressed me about your entire career
and the results that you've achieved is
how far you've been able to take it in
terms of working with say the top 1% of
performers in the world and I read in
your your new book which everyone should
take a look at we'll be delving into it
a lot more as we progress in the
interview but there was a quote from mr.
Benioff all sales force and who credits
you with effectively if there were no
Tony Robbins there would be no sales
force.com would be quite quick to make I
don't think it might have told me
exaggerated but he kind of walked me
through this it started very much like
um ah on the freeway it's no good
Valerie every day listening and you get
these you're able to reach such a high
caliber of individual when you meet with
such people whether they're presidents
athletes like Serena Williams Agassi
actors like Hugh Jackman whoever it
might be Benioff Scott was you know Tony
said to me that the quality of my life
was the quality of my questions so what
I would be curious to know is when you
meet with these top performers where do
you start what are the questions that
you ask them well I ask questions for I
meet them the question I want to ask
before I meet them is who are they what
are they made of what are they after
what's preventing them from getting it
where their wounds was their deepest
pride not in a negative way like what
are they proud of how to find as much as
I can in advance so that I can be really
effective and efficient when I meet them
when you meet somebody yourself myself
the most valuable thing we have is our
times I try to be beyond respectful of
that but also I load my brain with all
the distinctions I can so they want to
enter into an interaction with someone
more engaged I have a disproportionate
amount of information ideas insights
wisdom available to me and then I can
react to what's really happening in this
moment so I have what I think in advance
and then I have what what the moment
shows me and I I think the blend of that
is really valuable because in the moment
people can show up on all kinds of ways
right you know something to show the
meanest person on earth can be kind in
the moment yeah the kindest person could
be very mean in the moment right so I
really I liked I liked to grab both
those and then
do when I meet them is I want to try and
understand what is it that they really
need not only what they want right
because what you want I'm sure you've
experienced this I have my life gotten
what you want then you're like is that
where is like what the hell because what
really makes us fulfill human being is
what we need and there's only so many
needs so I dig under what the needs are
I look at what's their model the world
how they approach meeting those needs
and every model has limitations and
challenges mind yours anybody's and so
that tells me before I even meet them
where the real challenge is and that I
listen for what the surface challenges
and my goal is all the surface challenge
but also give them more than they
bargained for solve at the deeper
challenge ultimately my goal is that
they have a greater quality of life and
most people I work with have an
extraordinary life they may not realize
it they may have forgotten it I know
lost track of it unless I'm doing with
somebody which I also deal with who's
you know coming back from Afghanistan
with PTSD and they got light sensitivity
and they can't sleep at night they wake
up in cold sweats and they're shaking
while they're talking to me that's a
different game boom you know that's
something's got to be dealt with in a
different way but when you're talking
about peak performers their challenges
are usually they're hungry for more
right that's the nature probably people
listening to this there's a list of Tim
Ferriss there to listen for more it give
me something beyond what everybody else
is talking about and then you're always
seeking to try and find that by not
limiting it to yourself same as myself
let's go find whoever's best in these
areas and what I pulled together and
let's find the organizing principles
that codify this so I'm looking to
figure out you know what is that more
that they want and or what is it that's
stopping them and then I I go into the
experience and just absorb what's there
and the combination the two is how I'm
able usually get pretty extraordinary
results but without the prep when most
people know about me is the level of
prep on you right like I can get up and
my pinky do six days in a row without
you know I know turning that nature at
this stage that's not intelligence
that's experience that's a 40,000 hours
not 10,000 hours you know over the years
but I still prep because I what I do is
I activated my nervous system that
knowledge base of what I want to be able
to serve somebody with I try to bring
that to the surface so it's readily
available it's the difference between
emotional intelligence and what I call
emotional fitness emotional intelligence
is the key intelligence is the
capability to deliver something Fitness
is the readiness to be like that
happened so I am
stood in being emotionally fit or being
emotionally fit for that person in the
moment and when you when you interact
with people for instance Paul Tudor
Jones because legendary investor in
trader or Agassi or anyone who's at the
peak of their game and suddenly enters a
slump yes what are the commonalities if
any that you've spotted in the best of
the best
who then cease for a period of time
being the best of the best what triggers
that type of downslope everybody's got
different triggers there's some common
patterns one pattern is doing so well
that you go beyond your vision and you
know it's the astronaut syndrome you
know what do you do when you've you know
you're 31 years old you flew to the top
of the mountain right on top literally
look back at the earth inside the
picture we've all seen photograph come
back shake the president's hand have the
ticker tape parade okay now what he do
with the rest your life right and so
most those astronauts of you know their
histories they went through some really
tough times somewhere alcoholic some got
addicted to prescription drugs and so
you know in some cases that's why enter
people's worlds as they've done so well
they've called the market you know
almost hour by hour or a week in advance
and they made more money in a day than
most people have ever dreamed of when
everybody else lost their shirt and
everybody want to know what to do okay I
have done that now what do I do after
I've called the market during the worst
day in history you know most people lose
momentum men or they get distracted
because it's like we need something to
go for we all need what I call a
compelling future something that will
get us up really keep us up late and
excite us the least nature of a high
performer and if you don't have that
life feels very dead for those people
and so you know be present eight states
and ever Bill Clinton spanked me I was
with him in Aspen and I was there a
fundraiser and asked me to come visit
him and they threw me in the cards come
down the hill with me was on those
serene moments in the lights of flash
and would come down Red Mountain and
Aspen if you know the area and he said
crossing me that's right after the blue
dress incident to come out and he's a
Tony and it's just like I'm still so
young he said you know what am I gonna
do when I leave you know what I'm gonna
do my 50s that's the wildest thing as if
I were you I get the hell out quick
because he's talking about you know I've
run a third time if I could I was
teasing him about it but
he found a compelling future bill cuenta
de as something even greater in his life
that he's going for so the slump shows
when people outrun their vision or the
slump can show when they meet their
vision but it's not fulfilling or the
slump shows when people just end up
developing some patterns they're unaware
of that cost them and this can be so
such a small thing with an athlete that
can occur and sometimes it shows like a
Tiger Woods when something happens in
their emotional life and while they try
to say I'm an athlete here and I'm a
human being over there they don't
separate and so what I got to do in
those situations regardless of what
triggered it is I've got to come in and
get them to re-enter in their nervous
system what made them so effective and
you understand Milan the idea that the
more you do something the more you why
yourself it's like the myelin of the
white portion of the brain it's almost
like using if I do something over and
over again
I literally wire myself with this myelin
I'm it's like having high-speed you know
cable in there whatever the appropriate
I don't know what it is anymore
high-speed really is these days the
proper term but versus you know having
dial-up if you have something opened
over again you can process so much more
rapidly so I will find where is that
myelin and that person what specific
pattern will hook them back up again to
that part of their brain where it's
effortless to that part of the brain
where they in state and they don't even
think you know Andre Agassi was decades
and decades ago you've been number one
in the world and all sudden he dropped I
was number nineteen or something at that
stage it's like 90 91 92 whatever it was
and and nothing worked and nothing
worked because he kept working on his
swing and he kept working on his wrist
and he was really upset with his father
who was his coach there was all these
dynamics going nobody wants to talk
about he was actually the point he
chaired later on but he was thinking
about quitting you know playing the game
this is really early in his career and
you know he's gotten injured and Andre
is very frustrated and Brooke Shields
brought him to me they were just dating
at that time and said I don't need
positive thinking he said you know what
you know Tony's not positive thinking
he's going to show you these strategies
so he comes to me I sit down with him
and I said I said Andre he's telling me
about how he's doing this I said think
of a time he hit the tennis ball
perfectly I said don't think about go to
it I got him in state got him cut in
that place where the my lens being fired
off and then I said to him
feel that you feel that yeah gelsen were
you thinking about your wrist this is no
I said how the hell would you think you
would ever get back to that people are
focusing on your wrist right so I've got
to get them back into the pattern that
made it work and then oftentimes I've
got to help them resolve some other
issue that's distracting them that is
something else in their life that's
pulling and pulling them apart from peak
performance his story is an amazing one
open the autobiography is one of the
well I've ever read that's why it's such
a fantastic book just looking at the
longevity of your career the the scope
and scale of the Tony Robbins Empire so
to speak thus your endurance has really
impressed me and so I'm wondering after
these decades
what are your some of your daily
routines for instance what do you
typically eat for breakfast it's up to
you yeah I have salad and fish it's like
standard I'm boring as hell because I
just know it's fuel yeah um that now I
before I met my wife we've been together
more than 15 years
I was completely anal I was like I met
chocolate I had a net ice cream in like
15 years right I was just just crazy and
then she came into my life and I forget
I thought god this woman's incredible
she's a phlebotomist she does the blood
she's an acupuncturist
she's a nutritionist having these green
drinks and we had this lunch and that's
where she ordered a hot fudge sundae and
I got what and the hell are you doing
just living you bastard so she loosened
my ass up just a bit because I loved her
so I you know she calls it zigging and
zagging we Zig zig zag and then she zags
or we zag and when I was first with or
is like your Zagat we were traveling
through Europe you know Rome Italy and
you know various parts of France south
of France and it's like you know you
seem to be sagging every day it was well
I'm on vacation and then later on we
were traveling some I said you know the
problem is we're always traveling so the
girl is on vacation but she said is how
a great shape but I am fish fish and
then and salad I'm I'm a high greens you
know
protein type of guy very low carbs and
my but my regimen is I start with
something to strengthen a jolt my
nervous system
every second day I well sometimes he's
into and I'll go in the hot pools and
I'm fortunate that multiple homes my
home and Sun Valley have natural hot
pools that come out of ground to
steaming hot and I go on hot pools and
then I go there in the river here I go
in a 57 degree you know plunge pool that
I have and I put every home I have every
Sony agent immediately upon waking and
waking up it's just like boom every cell
in the body wakes up and it's also just
like training my nervous system to rock
that there is no I'm sure how you feel
this is how you perform what's what you
do even when a big vacation I do it it's
just I don't know now I like it it's a I
like that that simple discipline that
reminds me the level of strength and
intensity that's available any moment
even if I'm relaxing I can bring that up
at will its Milan I also have a
cryotherapy unit all my films are if
you've tried crowd therapy I haven't
you're it is uh maybe you could wait a
minute I can I can put the two words
together and I probably get my god but
all that you do you're gonna love this
I'm surprised I'm glad I'm teaching Tim
Ferriss up adventures I'm not the first
time I said suck I smell sucked recipe
I'm on stage in a weekend I do mind at
least I was in program three days it's
50 hours yeah you have been to then I
gotta come as my guest on events um I
would love to the but I'm gonna give an
idea people won't sit for a three-hour
movie that somebody spent 300 million
dollars on and I got like Usher
Oprah going on you know Tony I love you
but two hours most like you doing 12
hours later you know Oprah's standing on
a chair going this is the most
incredible experience of my life on
Cameron
I should like dude I'm in for all three
days but for me one of those days alone
I wear odometer and I'm Fitbit that's 26
and a half miles on average Wow
we start at 8:30 in the morning I finish
at 1:30 or two there's one one-hour
break people can vote with your feet no
one leaves
you know there's on average 20 minutes
of just crazy ass standing ovations
music stuff that happens the youngest
people are just it's like a rock concert
it's so much fun but the wear and tear
of doing know basically marathon after
marathon at the marathon on the weekend
and back-to-back it's pretty intense and
so over the years like the inflammation
my body the demands I've had do
everything to kind of reduce it nothing
has come close to go out there but
cryotherapy was developed in Poland and
eastern Germany and the Eastern Bloc
countries and what it does is it uses
nitrogen so there's no water and unlike
an ice bath what you're doing to get
spasms and you've got to do and still
write you're a boxer you're a runner
you're an athlete which is what I would
do before hated them
there's no none of that process but it
reduces your body temperature to minus
220 Fahrenheit and you do it three
minutes and it's mind-boggling I'm in
fact I happen here and I'll throw you in
at the end if you want not as we love to
dance I have a unit here I'll go for it
but what it does is and I do about three
times a week usually not and when I come
back from event I do it you know a
couple days in Rome and what it does is
it takes all the inflammation out your
body and you know what inflammation does
to every aspect the body in the
breakdown but it also it's it sends
emergency signals to your brains like
resetting your neurological system
because your brain going you're going to
freeze to death
it sounds horrific it really isn't
you'll find out it's not that painful
going in my cold plunge a 57 degrees
feels more jolting than this does even
that's cool even though it's colder
because you know the fluid of water
versus the nitrite is different right
the comedy the conductivity exactly
right and so but what happens is your
nervousness gets a signal so it's like
everything your body connects because
it's like emergency every part is a
reset of your nervous system you get an
explosion of endorphins in your body
which is really cool so you get this
natural high you feel this physiological
transformation and you get the reduction
of inflammation what it was used for
originally is for people with arthritis
and I found my first one because my
mother-in-law was be calling up and she
was just crying and pain and no
medication was enough for her and I hate
somebody medicated anyway and so I
started doing this research and it just
started come to the US and now the LA
Lakers most football teams that it's
spreading like wildfire amongst the
sports teams and so that's where it took
off so I went got her one and I mean
took her I think three sessions and
she's out of pain and now there's no day
she's in pain now most people can't
afford to go by unit but there are local
places now they're popping up all over
the United States where athletes go
where people go where people go for
adjuvants amazing to the skin but it's
one of the great things I got at first I
got it for me and then now I'm addicted
so I've got one every three minutes what
type of unit do you know the actual
model and Brandi oh yeah there's two
them the best out there it's was a Java
junkie
Ju and ka I think it is I'll get it for
you my ground stairs and I'll put it in
the show nets for the
everybody wants to do it but also like
if you're in LA there's there's a place
there on I'll give to you putting your
nails couple of locations there there's
some great guys I'm getting another unit
this is brand new home so I'm building a
you know an additional guest house and
ditional slides can and so forth I'm
going to eat it though that's better
this one it just goes up to your neck
and but I'm getting one that encloses
you a full room and the reason is about
70% of your Nerf's receptor so from the
neck up so when you step into one of
those it's even more powerful but I do
not undo much unique or different with
my life I believe entirely I'll keep
digging but the so you have the either
the sort of contrast therapy that you
mentioned the household the cryotherapy
yes you have salad and fish yes out how
far after so what is if you were to kind
of speck out the first hour of your day
well the first the first everyday I do
the water I take in the environment and
then the first thing I do for I do
anything else my days I do what I call
priming and priming to me is different
than meditating I'm never really a
meditator per se I know the value of it
but the idea for me of sitting still and
having no thoughts just didn't really
work out for me I was just a pain in the
ass and I just thought it's not natural
right is like that's what works but when
I'm in nature I feel that for meditation
when I stand on stage and someone stands
up and my brain it's done I only know
what it is but person suicidal I've
never lost the suicide for example and
you know 37 years not going to what does
it mean I won't some day but I never had
a thousands and we followed up with them
so it's like there's something that
comes through me and it's and it's quite
meditative it's like I experienced it as
a witness you know afterwards it's one
of the beautiful gifts in my life so I
know that meditation um but for me we're
planning is if you want to be have a
prime life you got to be in a prime
state and you know weeds grow
automatically I don't give a damn what
it is it might teach Jim Rohn just to
say that and so what I do is I get up
and I do a very simple process I do an
explosive change in my physiology I've
done the water already right cold hot
then I do it with breath because I know
you know all forms of Eastern meditation
all understand that the mind is the kite
and breath is the string so if I want to
move that kite I move the breath so I
have a specific pattern of breathing
that I do I do 30 of these breaths
and I do him it three sets of thirty
that creates a profound physiological
difference in my body and from that
altered state I usually listen to some
music and and I go for I promised myself
ten minutes and I usually go 30 and you
get that misremember sitting I know I do
it all of this one room is where I do it
this has got a great vibe I'll do this
one I do it at night I usually will go
outside cuz I love the wind on my face
and I love taking the elements and so
forth but I do it multiple places I'm on
the road I do it doesn't matter what day
only that I do not miss priming the
reason is I'm not but you don't get fit
by getting lucky you don't get fit by
working out for a weekend you know you
live your life that way fitness is
because it's becomes just part of who
you are so what I do during that time is
I do three simple things and I do it
minimum ten minutes three minutes of it
is just me feeling getting back inside
my body and outside of my head feeling
earth my body experience and then
feeling totally grateful for three
things and I make sure one of them is
something very very simple the wind on
my face
you know the reflection of the clouds
that I just saw there but I don't just
think gratitude that like I let
gratitude fill my soul because when
you're grateful as we all know there's
no anger it's possibly angry and
grateful simultaneously when you're when
you're grateful there is no fear you
can't be fearful and grateful
simultaneously so it's it's a I think it
is one of the most important power
emotions of life and also up to me
there's nothing worse than an angry rich
man or woman you know somebody's got
everything and they're pissed off when
it's right only high number that it is
because they they develop a life that's
based on expectation instead of
appreciation agreed and I tell people
you want to change your life faster than
trade your expectation for appreciation
you have a whole new life so every day I
heard that in and I do it very deeply
emotionally then the second three
minutes I do is a total focus on feeling
presence of God if you will however you
want a language that for yourself but
this inner presence coming in and
feeling that heals everything in my body
my mind my emotions my relationships and
my finances I see it as solving anything
needs to be solved I experience the
strengthening of my gratitude of my joy
of my strength of my conviction of my
passion and I just let those things
happen spontaneously and I focus on
celebration and then service because my
whole life is about service that's what
makes me feel alive
so I flood myself with that with a
breathing pattern that I take that does
the opposite takes the breath down
through my body and back up again and
then the last three minutes are me
focusing on three things I'm going to
make happen my three two three and I
have some big things that I'll do and
sometimes I'll do things that are
smaller but I see them filled and
experience them so it's a really
simplistic process ten minutes but I
come out of it in my power it doesn't
matter if I had two hours sleep I'm now
ready you know it doesn't and I do this
even I have no sleep that's how
committed I am as I say I've always said
there's no excuse not to do ten minutes
I mean if you don't have ten minutes you
don't have a wife right and that's how I
got myself to do it and now that I've
done it you know twenty to thirty
minutes is almost always what it is
because it actually feels extraordinary
and where can people learn more about
the breathing pattern or could you
describe it I'm putting a link on why
because I just started to share this
just recently and I'll get it for you I
don't know what has not taught me yet
but they'll be up shortly I think this
week okay awesome and I'll also put that
in the show notes guys so that's just
for our workweek comm forward slash
podcast and you'll be able to find this
episode only I have to ask what type of
music do you usually listen to well I
have a variety but for that meditation I
have one in particular which is a
oneness meditation that a friend of mine
made it foods from India that I find
really profound as no singing and
anything like that is just the sound of
a vibration that's going on and I just
love it but that's what I'm doing
currently in the past over the years
I've used all kinds of different piece
music but I don't use modern music or
pop music or rock we I just have to work
out you know rap I know it just feels
weird to be doing rap while you're
meditating but again what's Dubin is I
don't leave this meditation because I
look at it as it's the priming courage
love joy its priming gratitude it's
priming strength it's priming
accomplishment it's priming you know
when I'm doing my gratitude piece I'm
doing the circle of who's closest to me
and you know circling that out to
everybody I love and sending that energy
and healing out to them as well so to me
that's if you want primetime life you
got a prime daily well I like I like the
term priming also because I think that
most people who struggle with meditation
or even attempt to use meditation are
utilizing it for that purpose they're
doing it first in the morning and you
know when you said if you have 10
minutes you don't have a life right of
me of something that Russell Simmons
said to me which was if you don't have
30 minutes to meditate you need three
hours
and I don't always do 30 minutes but I
do meditate in the morning and it's been
a canary consistent pattern through
among all the people that I've
interviewed so far on the podcast really
practically a hundred percent well
that's one uh and of course we'll get to
Ray Dalio but yes also very avid
meditator he's coming with me to India
in a couple weeks well that'll be an
amazing for a week of this experience oh
mazing so the when people hear the name
Tony Robbins I think many different
people have different assumptions or
images in their in their heads what are
the biggest misconceptions or the
biggest misconception about you oh my
god tell you so many right that's how
you talk to you know when you've been in
the culture at any level for any period
of time people put their projections out
to what you are and then also you know I
didn't help myself I did infomercials at
a time but you know I didn't want to do
infomercials there's just I had these
insights and skill sets and I didn't
have it if I was a great singer which
I'm clearly not there was a distribution
channel right I could do that if I
wasn't bullshitting myself I could rock
the world but in my world was write a
book which must be put on read go do
some speeches so I looked around saw
these silly-ass infomercials and I said
these guys are a disaster
Tommy vu come be on my boat watch me get
these women and I'm rich and I'm like oh
my god it's disgusting so I thought you
know if you really did something that
was real and the kind of people I reach
you know I'd like to pay for
endorsements they'll do it you know
maybe people start to understand this is
real and maybe they help me reach people
and it did it got me Bill Clinton that
got me prince panat got me I got me a
pretty amazing group of people Penn
State but also you know my the company
keeps so when you're between spray-on
hair and you know you know whatever it
is you make diamonds but you know then
you you know you've seen as that and
also I talk fast I'm a passionate son of
a [ __ ] and so I'm not talking about
shows I'm dressed cells I'm talking
about cuz my brain functions that speed
right that's how my brain goes slowing
it down is just so boring to me I
brought the faster I go the stronger my
brain becomes the quicker I come to
solutions so you know when I'm most
excited I want to serve people it speeds
up so that helps when you've got a room
of people where you can move and
modulate that energy but when you're
seeing somebody on TV and they look like
they're crazy sombitch in their six
seven and they got hands big
than your head you know you start going
you know who is this guy with the people
that have actually like yourself or Marc
Benioff or you know President Clinton or
whoever who you know actually entered
into my work once they entered in my
work they go oh my god this is very
difference I think most people think in
a commercial guy or salesman or a
motivator I mean I hate the word
motivate is the bane of my existence
because I've never been that I've never
I don't believe you should just go pump
yourself up I believe in intelligence I
believe see things as they are if you
can see his yard you can't lead alright
but don't see it worse than it is you
got an excuse not to try that's what
most people do they make it much worse
than it is because they're afraid of
failings they come up with a reason why
a story why it's not there and I don't
tolerate that [ __ ] I'm not the guy that
says there's no way there's no weak
something I go let me show you the
goddamn weeds aren't less police every
[ __ ] is out right now stop bullshitting
let's do it you know I'll do it with you
that's my approach I think most people
think it's a public approach because you
know the media sees 10,000 people in a
room and they're jumping up and down and
you know you know what is this piece so
that's because I believe that learning
that the I believe what I do for people
at its essence when I do events is he
cubed them
EQ biz I entertain them first because
people in our society want to be
educated but they'd much rather be
entertained so if I can rock you and get
you to have an experience where you feel
fully alive then and doesn't matter who
you are you're you know you're from any
stage of life any socio-economic
background then I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
going to be able to have your education
go deeper and then so that's the second
part I give you the best education the
best tools and the third one is I
empower you while you're in this date I
get you to do things that you won't
forget two things that will be in your
body do things that create momentum so I
think the misconception at least my
perception is they don't realize I'm
really a strategist I mean I consider
you a strategist and I know your
inspirational everything else but being
inspiring is nice you know it's like
motivation is nothing wrong with it it's
like warm baths you should take one or
you stink you know but but but that's
not enough that's never been what I've
been about but you know most people in
our society our interesting days like if
you're looking to improve yourself
people in our world think that's natural
the average person's like what's wrong
with you I remember I had the I took a
company public when I was what 39 years
old had really wonderfully had 40
million bucks
extraordinary and the man who ran my
company been the former CEO of CBS
brilliant guy brilliant guy Peter and
Peter at one point while were in the
midst of this company he said I want to
go to Harvard I want to take this
extension course you know very wealthy
guy but head of the largest networks in
the world and now heading up my company
and I remember three or four people like
well it's a matter why is he doing that
he lost his agile it's like versus life
is growth baby if you don't keep growing
you're gonna die I didn't you know but
those people are afraid of the unknown
they're afraid of I'm not looking good
I'm afraid to fail and so that creates a
challenge but so I think the answer
question is they don't know I'm
strategist they don't know how much I
really care they have no clue the depth
of what I teach or the diversity when I
teach subject your body your mind your
motions relationships your finances they
don't know the real impact or they don't
know who I really work with you know the
assumption is he's taking over weak
people's minds and pumping them up and
giving him all systems upon them that's
crazy [ __ ] but but I'm not here to try
to dispel that what I try to do is the
reason I'm still here is the more people
you touched the more you reach I don't
have to do that the people have been
through my events are the greatest
people to balance that out in social
media it's been really wonderful because
people say well this what this guy isn't
twelve other people go you've never had
experience let me tell what this really
is about that's really been a wonderful
handsome it to my ability to reach
people with social media no I just to
reiterate something you said about
inspiration being necessary but not
sufficient I think that like you having
the label sort of motivation or
motivational speaker applied to what I
try to do is very frustrating because
one of the things that differentiate
with that label of YouTube oh yeah I
don't know it's just an easy label to
throw right now it's like what else it's
like well I'm not going to read the book
so I might as well find a label that I
can understand and you know I was going
to say at least you get an infomercial
but at least you weren't selling the
4-hour workweek on those infomercials
you have twice the level of hell that
you already get but the the the the
difference in your material because I
really want to better myself when I was
hitting some very rough spots in my
first year out of school
and the difference between say personal
power and a lot of your other material
including the new book on on money and
finance and investing which you guys at
some point I'll try to share some of it
with you but I have I would say probably
20 to 30 printed pages of notes in
Evernote well just on just on I still
have about 50 pages left but it's it's a
big book we'll get to that I was calling
giving you a pat on the back it's like
Oh another 600 page book I know how
these go but you give very tactical next
steps at the proper time so you you you
do sugarcoat the medicine a bit by
getting capturing people's attention and
not to make this Glengarry Glen Ross you
know AI da but you you have to have
those elements in the proper sequence or
you can't elicit action from people
that's right and that's something that
you've got huge you've been very
influential on my teaching which is how
I would view my writing because of that
model and so if you look at say the
4-hour workweek is one instance the
reason that I have these comfort
challenges at the end of each chapter is
because I know I'm going to have big
asks later and I want to condition
people yes to take action I think that
your materials it means some of the best
in the world I've ever seen in that
asset II I want to say some of what you
said because it's really important and
you're the few people I've heard
actually notice it and I've noticed it
in your work and I just I didn't know
what influenced by me anyway I'm
complimented by that but I think you
probably got there on your own just by
the nature of your thinking the dog bit
Johnny Johnny bit the dog same exact
words different syntax totally different
experience specially if you're Johnny
and people don't realize it sometimes
when they think on thirty pounds
overweight and I'll never get this I've
tried everything or I've you know my
knife on every relationship sucks you
know how do I end up with men or women
like this or you know this is my third
business and I'm still not there and
I'll say that's going to happen they
don't realize that victory is near and
the reason is it feels like a million
miles away and they're doing the right
things but at the wrong time or they
were doing the wrong things you know
they're doing the right things the wrong
sequence you know I mean so there's
timing is so and I want some of
you and I know we can't control some of
those freaking luck but the more you
study how things grow or the bee
organizations or human beings or
families or communities or the way in
which people you know study ontology or
study of knowledge there's a sequence
it's like I know somebody's phone number
and I dialed the wrong order I don't
reach them but I do that same exact
ingredients the right over and that's
what people need very often often they
just need a slight twist and they don't
know it and they give up and so my part
of my passion is to help people find
that two millimeters you know that
little tiny shift that changes it all
one of the people I have these people
that I've coached over the years that
are the best in the world at what they
do and and I'll take on clients who I
think by touching them I can touch in
mass number people that's I start with
Paul Tudor twenty one years ago and it's
turned out really well with his Robin
Hood group growing image giving away a
billion to over this time and the impact
that's had but one of these people is
one of the top two even idea facial
surgeons in the world and I remember
want to go see him one day for one of
our sessions and he was late and I'm
waiting and I'm no problem I'm busy and
the nurse says he's gonna be a while she
says he said dr. Hoffman said why don't
you come in and watch I said wow love
that so you know I get all scrubbed off
the whole thing come in he's got rock
and roll music in there and this guy is
like an artist and a scientist mixed
together the most powerful blend with a
giant heart and I go into the music's
blaring hey Tony hey he won't watch this
he cuts his like it lifts this woman's
face off I felt a little state change
and that's my god you know I stayed
around for a few minutes just you know
to put up that I can handle this [ __ ]
and I said you know I got a few calls I
got a fake so I go into his office just
use my office make a call so I'm
recovering in his office here a basket
and they're using uh I'm not a squeamish
guy without was I just wasn't prepared
right so I'm sitting his office and he's
in front of stage of life where you know
this is a guy that sultan of brunai paid
two million dollars to fly him over like
15 years ago 20 years ago to do to his
family's faces this is a guy that
anybody in Hollywood who had the money
he's in those days there's no
but him the best on earth because he
mathematically figured out how to
trigger beauty by what you and I would
call sub modalities like I'd Chuck a
shorthand for you an NLP term right
those little triggers in the visual
triggering device that effect
kinesthetic change in human being and so
I'm sitting at his desk a he's got this
manuscript so I'm curious and then he
was working on and he wants to finally
teach other surgeons because he sold is
one of just himself anymore
he wants his material not to die and
he's got a hundred and maybe 150
pictures the most beautiful in the world
the last twenty years across culturally
around the world stars movie stars
different countries they've got the same
thing for men and then he's got his
drawings and he showed that just ironic
he goes through these shows that he
makes no more than seven changes ever
and the biggest change he makes is two
millimeters and yet I saw an 84 year old
woman look like she was an early 50s and
gorgeous and that's all the changes he
made on her I'm telling you it's
mind-boggling and for example he knows
that the measurement of the pupil of a
woman's ID you measure that size and you
measure the distance below your nose to
the top of a woman's lip is for only for
a woman if that measurement is smaller
than the people there i men when they
look at this woman's face are driven and
sexually attracted to her if it's the
same size of people there's attraction
if it's just two millimeters more she
has an average face if it's more than
two millimeters more her face is what he
calls but as ugly that was a technical
term used at that point but so when I
taught whether this like start measuring
their eye hits them so he makes this
little change and it creates that
puckered feeling that men don't even
know why it's instinctive it's just a
triggering device that's instinctual
them so he knows the seven he knows the
two millimeters and of like you take
somebody 8450 and looking pretty out
high and maybe up to a twenty role put a
30 or 40 or 50-year old certainly
mind-boggling so I've always like it's
like golf right you know two millimeters
the difference between you know shanking
way over here I'm putting it on the
green so that's the whole thing victory
is near but you've got to know that very
often syntax is all that has to change
there's nothing wrong with you there's
nothing wrong with the core ingredients
got a sequence of different yeah so you
mentioned a few things the first is that
hand bigger than someone's head or face
I think that for everyone listening at
some point I would like to see if you
can actually palm
face and I'll put that out on social
media cuz I'm pretty sure that you can
and I'm sure everybody would love to see
they're probably a lot of people
listening you don't like me very much I
would like to pull my face so Tony will
step in for you later
the I'd love for you to mention a little
bit about the new book and just sort of
a very basic overview and then I have a
bunch of specific questions because this
is the first book in 20 years
where's 20 years and I've read pretty
much everything that you've put out that
I'm aware of
yes and I guess part of me thought a few
things when I saw that this book was
related to to money and also referring
to it as a game in some ways I thought
number one what hasn't already been said
there's so many books with the problems
there's so many books on money and I
think that perhaps undeservedly so I
feel like I understand a lot as it
relates to investing and money and I've
read David Swensen I've read about his
allocations I've read the annual letters
of Warren Buffett I read the letters to
shareholders from people like Howard
Marx or other hedge fund managers I know
some of those guys so I saw a couple
names pop up that I recognized and I was
and you send the very beginning the book
and this is I've tried to do stuff like
this in the past so I realize how hard
it is you're trying to write a book that
the the neophyte someone who's never
taken their finances seriously will
derive a lot of value from and yet at
the same time you say even very
sophisticated investors will be able to
get a lot out of this book and I thought
to myself well boy this is really
talking a big game and uh the I mean the
interviews at the end of the book alone
are worth magnitude of order more than
the book itself me about Bogle you've
got Ray Dalio
who runs that believe it's still largest
hedge larger cells from the world
largest mutual fund with Bogle Arts
hedge fund with Ray Dalio a Carl Icahn
who's you know Time magazine put him on
the covers master of the universe
this guy that sends out one tweet and
Apple goes up 17 billion in an hour
that's up 50% I was out use that do it
and today I don't know if you saw Carl's
quite a character ya know that two
things one
coming what you said that's the
challenge I love when I do my business
mastery programs I bring people in from
usually somewhere between 15 and 30
countries I translate four or five
languages there are different financial
systems but business the psychology and
the strategies of business
it's a worldwide game yeah and as I
bring people in there that are brand new
they come in like just start a business
and you got people in there like home
acts largest home builder Mexico is when
my events you know a billion dollar
business and I they credit me with seven
or fifteen million dollars increase in
two years I was doubling the business
and I take this chiropractor or this
dentist you know an army of three and so
I'm gonna W business in six months so I
love that challenge of how do you get
both and it's not easy to do area that's
far I think we pulled it off and pull it
off primarily because of who I not me
doing the teaching it's me going the
best unearthing getting them some [ __ ]
you only the same thing um you know
people said why did you write a book in
20 years and how you've been doing well
about every four days I'm an airplane I
see a quarter million people a year in
15 countries that's what that I'm doing
and I love I live for that environment
the rawness the aliveness the every
moments on the stage you never know
who's gonna stand up you don't know what
the challenge is gonna be I mean that
feels alive and also it's just real and
it's now and if it's not working
fricking change it who cares but I got
to write this I did 20 years ago
I'm sitting still and I'm at first oh
well makes me crazy and then number two
you know you took like my hands my music
my voice my face my intensity and now I
just got written words which I clearly
might have skilled that but when I
conjugated I am but I also go this is
immortal I can't improve this you know
it's like what you write the [ __ ] it's
done so I've avoided it like the plague
and then also most people don't read
frankly yeah it's true they read blogs
you know it's like most people I can see
a generation looking at this book it's
600 in what 30 pages right but it's
these seven steps so you can do a
chapter a day thirty days you got a
different financial life that's work
you're crazy like what you'll do in the
weekend you know but what's interesting
is they'll say you know why don't you
put this in a blog you know why don't
you put this in an infographic mastery
doesn't come from an infographic what
you know it doesn't mean [ __ ] yeah what
do you do consistently and you got to go
through stages of understanding
intellectually which anybody can do but
you got to do and you got to get word
there's nothing
emotional intensity attached that
understanding that you actually do it
and you got to get enough consistent
vocals that gets in your body not two
feet about it it becomes who you are and
those stages of mastery require it's
like I I took Taekwondo I didn't want
Taekwondo I wanted to learn Aikido
because I was a beautiful art you know
and I like the idea they have to hurt
somebody
ten people attack you at once and it's
like wonderful heal so I learned some
Aikido but I had the privilege of being
exposed to grab Master June Rhee who
brought Taekwondo to this country any
trained Muhammad Ali and he trained
Bruce Lee and his back you punch and so
forth amazing history and a beautiful
man like the most happy human being ever
meet and he loved me and what I did was
touched by it and he said would you like
to do this and I was 23 24 so I said yes
but I must get my black belt fastest
time in human history and you must come
travel with me we will do this every day
I don't like you're insane all right I
read your book in two days it's like
completely insane so he came and I
finished being onstage at midnight or
1:00 a.m. and then I had to go train
from 1:00 to 4:00 and then I'd sleep
from four to seven thirty three and a
half hours four hours sometimes dey'd if
I could squeeze it get up and do my next
day I didn't ever you know nine months I
did get a black belt legitimately in the
shortest time history but I hated never
want to do it again but I'll never
forget I was doing these moves and it's
like she is 4:00 in the morning I'm
doing the same freaking move and I've
done over and over and over again and I
said mystery I said can we go to the
next move and he said grasshopper this
is the next move it on he started laughs
he goes the fact that you think this and
this is the same move is why we're still
doing it it's like I like but you know
what it was really true so I'm into
mastery and so what I really want to
make sure happen with people is that
that we got them to that place and when
I went to Simon Shuster there's a crazy
thing so I'm doing these events alumnus
I'm she's been begging me for a book for
decades a huge contracting that bigger
and bigger and I said only the money I'm
not doing with the money so they finally
came back and I what triggered me is I
saw this documentary called inside job
yeah great yeah Matt Damon did the audio
on it and it won all kinds of awards but
what's happened if you didn't see it I
really recommend you see it but I do
want to prepare you at the end you're
either extremely pissed off or you
really
depending upon your personality and I
was pissed off because they show how a
small number of people basically put the
entire economic world at risk and and
when they put us near imploding the
punishment for that was to reward them
by putting in the charge of the recovery
printing more money and then taxing
everybody else on earth and giving their
money back just my it's the greatest
thievery that's happened in human
history and so I thought this is making
a because there's no solution and I
thought there's got to be a solution I
thought you know well I got access the
one thing I got access because I call
you know coach Paul for 21 years and I
mean he's never lost money in 21 years
and mine Bobby his company's never lost
in 28 years I was brought in when he's
having a tough time to help take things
to the next level and I thought I know
these people I know this process what if
I took with the ultra-wealthy nutball
out and brought it in so I think I got
this great strategy but assign Mystery's
wanted book forever the first thing he
says no way you get tell me know your
Tony no you know Jonathan's your brain
man turn to carpet study you don't want
to do this he goes people are dying for
a book on peak performance for you're
dying for a book on anything but not
finance this this category is a dead
carcass is what he said it's been picked
clean sandbender sailer I qur'anic like
so did the head of the financial
division he goes there's nothing new to
say I said that's because everybody's
attacked the same way I'm gonna go to
the people that know nothing platitudes
of the same BS he actually offered me a
larger advance to not new financial book
and I said what I'm not doing it for
that I'm in for this book and so now
he's really through which is really
wonderful in fact the head of that
division came back and said he said I
really thought the categories dead I had
the division he goes this is a wife so
I'm real proud of it but I think what's
great about the book is there's not a
word in there that's coming from me on
the financial side I don't tell you my
opinion who gives a [ __ ] with my opinion
is I want to write values opinions owner
Jack Boggs man I want no car likens but
no no no it Mary Callahan Erdos who's
head of JP Morgan and manages 2.3
trillion with a t I want to know her
opinion when it comes to the emotional
psychological side yeah that's my baby
for 36 years
those big nerds are clearly mine I'll
stand on them so I'm real proud of what
it is and I think anybody reads it will
be touched and I wrote it to empower
readers of all pipes but I also wrote it
because I was looking thinking about a
vehicle
or writing another wrong in my opinion I
think the system is clearly you know
guys you know if you read Flyboys or you
talked to Michael Lewis or anybody like
and they'll describe to you how
high-frequency trading today is so
extreme we've all heard about it but
it's just so extreme it takes 500
milliseconds for you to click on your
each trade and say I want to buy the
stock of Apple and you got guys that
have spent a quarter of a billion
dollars to straighten lines with using
Chicago New York so they can save 1.4
milliseconds and they're going to trade
hundreds maybe thousands of times they
know you're going after Apple they know
what to do to make money little micro
profits one of the H of T groups was
going to go public last year said into
their filings you know how many losing
days they had in four years and you're
not one one losing day in four years
it's front-running so the system's
rigged but even though it's rigged you
can still win that's why I wrote this
book I want you you can still win and
here's how to win and here's the people
showing you how to win so I want to
write that wrong I wanted people to have
an advocate but I also I'm pretty
passionate about take care of people as
society's forgotten and I decided in
Italy I wanted that like raise my game
they they cut eight point seven billion
dollars in food stamps last summer most
people didn't notice it it's equivalent
every family who's being supported going
without food for one week out of the
month for 12 straight months and I've
been supporting I've you know my family
was fed when I was 11 years old I had no
food family this man came by and
delivered a turkey and food he was just
the delivery guy changed my life and
made me believe strangers care so I
cared about strangers I've been paying
it forward and I've said 42 million
people in 37 years this year I'm going
to feed 50 million people and myself
personally I'd started what I'm gonna
dance the book I'm gonna I'm gonna wait
and sell books and see how it goes I'm
just gonna dance all that was like well
I want I don't want to do ten nine
hundred twenty million to thirty so now
I'm doing fifty million and I'm getting
matching funds I have feeding America
delivering the food and I'm getting
matching funds targeting a hundred
million people this year alone and then
I'm putting a system in place to sustain
to sustain that so doing this book has
been opening up doors to thinking larger
because when you're sitting with Carl
Icahn and he goes yeah I just closed the
deal today I made two billion dollars
two billion the day I was there after
only 18 months of investment where he
put anything every start was a small
number in net finet flex yeah I made it
that day and he's now putting all this
money in a polito's you know does it
little tweet and 17 billion of value
goes up right away or you're sitting
with Kyle bass who took 30 million and
turned in a two billion to two years in
the middle the sub-prime god you know
crisis and again tell me that's like
holy cow I mean I started learning
things which it changes the scale of
your thinking so I'm babbling here
because what I want people know is two
things yes I think this truly if you
give yourself the gift of this book it's
a category breaker but it'll show you
step by step but I go where you where
you want to be if you're highly advanced
you're going to learn out of the 55 plus
say 50 but is really 55 plus Nobel
laureate self-made billionaires henchmen
guys biggest in the world
I put the 12 biggest in the book and you
know I wanted these guys with a the
promise of a 45-minute interview of my
average one was three hours so I know
how you functions I do the same thing
but what was really cool but it's like
you don't go with a Carl and I get there
with Carl the first thing he does is he
throws the video crew out it's like Carl
what's the deal I never met her before
he's like no I said I just changed my
mind
like okay how did you leave you will do
the audio no I don't what the audio no I
want to do this interview take your
pencil and your pen here get over here
and I said I'll give you ten minutes
right and you know Howard your friends
and it's you know three hours later I'm
out you know pictures of you his wife
then you know and he said you got it
really you got a way to help change this
world you know at any doors of the book
and supports it so I want people to know
that this has been a four year journey
of going to the smartest people on earth
and finding out the vast majority of
them are incredibly genuine and wanting
the average person to do well they just
didn't think there was anybody who could
translate and when they saw that I could
and I could pitch and catch with him
because I knew eighteen hours of prep
before I sit down with Ray Dalio they
won't want to share things that they've
never shared before it later on me we
can talk about what I learned from my
dad it was pretty amazing oh yeah no I
do want to talk about Ray and
fascinating guy I mean I'm so
fascinating at the entire world I mean
whether it's and there's so many
different breeds this is something I
want to talk about but you have say the
Paul Tudor Jones for those who probably
haven't ever seen a very old
I think it's available like bootleg VHS
called the traitor yes is an amazing old
documentary you can find it I but you
can see his style versus say you know
the high frequency guys or a renaissance
yes at all PhD is right outside of wall
street's but and once and then you have
the the Ray Dalio types and all things
in common if you look a lot of different
strategies if it's summer let's let's
let's shake the tree of the corporate
guys and make sure we get more value out
of it right now Carl you know and some
guys are like Templeton I got dated him
multiple times for he died it's like
wait for it you know the bloodletting no
one the streets that's an advice on the
streets but it's like when maximum
pessimism hits that's when you make all
your money that's what he did and then
there's the guys like bold which is it's
the index baby and and Wednesday's even
more above it it's the index baby so
they hope you approaches but what's in
common I think is I tell you four things
I thought stood out and one is overly
simplistic and that's why people don't
pay attention to but these guys pay
attention to it they don't lose half the
Pico linking is not losing and they are
obsessed every single one is obsessed
they're not losing money I mean a level
of obsession that's mind-boggling and it
isn't just these investors you know Sir
Richard Branson for example you know
people see Richard and he's such an
outgoing playful crazy guy kind of
introverted that's hilarious but when it
comes to athletics and taking on
challenges he's out in the world but you
know his first question every business
is let's the downside now I protect it
right like when he did his piece with
virgin I mean that's a big risk and
start an airline
he went to Boeing and negotiated a deal
they could send the planes back of it
didn't work out he wasn't liable without
the lovelies guys think that so they
look to see how do I not lose money
first because the average person has no
clue if I lose fifty percent in 2008
well guess what you got to make a
hundred percent to get even not fifty
percent because your principles gone
down so I should have like people don't
understand you lose 60 percent it's two
hundred percent to get even and so the
average person you know lives in a world
where they try not to lose money but
they're not obsessed these are obsessed
second thing you all have in common
every single one of them is obsessed
with asymmetrical risk/reward which is a
big word it's simply
means they're looking to use the least
amount of risk to get the max amount of
upside and that's what they live for
so I'll give an example Paul Tudor when
I first went to do the turn around when
Paul was having some challenging times
we broken his leg you know think about
this he did better than anybody in
history of the world during the big
stock market drop in history literally
and then he went to the mountain he went
to the moon now what and so lost a bit
of the edge and you know got involved in
other things and so forth and now he's
got a broken leg he's not going the
office I got to come inside and go watch
that film it's first thing I did I will
light tennis shoes I wanted to go see
everything about him and study his
physiology the way he used to move this
guy's not moving at all what his face
was like I would breathe tone of his
voice
what were the physical strategies what
were the psychological strategy or the
financial strategies I got to go you
know to Druckenmiller and Soros I mean
the word got access to vac that was
unbelievable see what was he like then
to put the Planum together to do this
turn around and when I started making
those shifts in him and you can see the
shift happen immediately they got really
exciting I got hooked on what was going
to happen so as I did this same process
basically guess what I was triggered I'm
think about do things once I did the
same process during these interviews I
didn't just look at the trading
strategies I looked at the psychology
what set it up but here's what I found
with Paul to the very beginning in him
back on track when he was at his best he
made sure every single trade had what he
called a 5 to 1 that means if he was
gonna risk a dollar he wasn't about to
risk unless he was certain he was gonna
make five now you're not always right so
guess what if I risk it all to make five
and I'm wrong I can risk another dollar
I still make four I can be ruined four
times out of five I still break even
their secret is not the theta they're
not wrong if they set themselves up
where they risk small amounts for big
rewards proportionally pull you know
he's right at one hour three times he
still makes twenty percent so the
average person wrists a dollar trying to
make how much dollar 10-track about but
if I could get 10% Wow my dollar I have
20% would be unbelievable how often can
you be wrong not very often not at all
right you're in the hole you're starting
from the hole you got to build back up
so they're a significant worth like I
was with Kyle Bass and
ass risk - check this out in the middle
of the subprime crisis he made two
billion dollars out of 30 million
because he risked for every six cents he
risked he had an upside of a dollar
six cents four hundred well you get me
wrong 15 times and you're still looking
at her I mean he was brilliant to figure
it out he's a genius figured out but
that risk reward is why it is he showed
his kids he ties how do I teach us to
the average investors in it and he said
that well you could teach the laptop my
kids and I said you know he goes
we bought nickels and so what do you
mean you bought nickels he said well I
did research I had this question that's
another thing that all these guys did
they ask a better question we talked
about they get better answers right
better quality question better quality
answer what's wrong with me you'll come
up with stuff how do I make this happen
no matter what they'll come up with
different answers so his question was
where in the world is there a riskless
trade with total upside and he started
looking around he said I'm worried about
inflation so he decided oh gosh of all
the currencies in the world a nickel
what it's made of today it's not made
mostly of nickel by the way he said it's
costing the US government nine and a
half cents to make a nickel that's how
our government functions it was been
almost ten cents to make something with
half as much right depending on plan
yeah
perfect plan so he said but you know
what just the actual material value
right is 628 whatever was six something
six and half will call for round numbers
so he said if I buy a nickel it's never
going less than a nickel I should
believe the US government's gone so I've
got something that never goes down in
value so I got a guaranteed return you
know I'm not gonna lose my principle but
day one it's worth 36% more than the day
I bought it
how many investments can you have a 100%
guarantee of no Osun if 36% I said yeah
but that's melt value and I saw they
passed the law a few years ago like
Charlie Rangel ever was this was what I
pushed it through and goes yeah but Tony
said that doesn't matter let me tell you
why you said look at pennies when they
changed it from pure copper to 10 and
all the things they've changed what
happened to the old pennies there's a
scarcity of them and now a penny from
those days they're worth two cents it's
a hundred percent more valuable so he
said that at some point the government
cannot continue to do something cost
twice as much some point they'll make a
change in the materials and then all
these nickels worth an unbeliever melt
so he said I just showing my kids here's
a risk
you need think different than everybody
else don't think I have to take huge
risk for huge awards say how do I take
no risk and get your drawers and because
you asked that question continuously and
you believe in answer you get it so you
know he said listen if I could put mine
to convert my entire wealth and matrix
that I do and I said you're insane
because I haven't say but it's the best
possible fundamental investment he
started telling me how to do
he bought 40 million nickels Wow he has
40 million nickels goes up a room bigger
than this right there's the on the
ground floor yet his kids dragging them
here else laughing have in front of you
this like the old treasures so he can
legitimately do like the scrooge mcduck
backstroke painful and real say so so
that's a summer school I'll give you one
more and I'll shut the hell up like
you're asking me that with it you tell
me the difference is the one you know
there are differences we've spent hours
now the difference is by the way things
useful is what's a wine because then it
gives something Universal that you apply
absolutely now the other one for them is
they absolutely beyond a shot of a doubt
no they're going to be wrong you look on
these talking heads on television of
people screaming you and hitting bells
and telling you what to buy and they're
right right right
the best on earth or a values right the
the pebbles that you know I don't give
it he'll you talk about you want to look
at Carl Icahn they all know they're
gonna be wrong so they set up a NASA
location system that will make them
successful they all agree asset
allocation is the single most important
investment there was one person in terms
of your vehicle that was the most
important thing about how they attacked
it asset allocation was the element
there and the last one is they are their
lifelong learners I mean these people
are machines like you like me like Peter
like most people you and I share his
friends they just are obsessed with
knowing more now because the more they
know the more they realize what they
didn't know and then they apply that and
they go to another level and every time
you think you're the best you can be in
anything in life your body or motion
spirit your finances
there's always another level and these
guys live by and the last one I thought
almost all the more real givers not just
give her some surface like money givers
that's wonderful but really passionate
about giving and it showed up once they
saw what I was doing was legitimate that
was really real that I mean then they're
opening up three hours at a time
something whether these guys will never
get oh yeah I mean their hours are worth
a lot
I say no Heath thank you for supporting
the sponsors of this show I've used them
I liked them and I think you will too
99designs comm forward / Tim it's the
world's largest marketplace of graphic
designers you can see the projects that
I've put up the competitions that I've
spearheaded including the book cover of
the 4-hour body and you can also get a
$99 upgrade for free so check it out at
99 designs com forward slash Tim of
course you can subscribe to this show on
iTunes you can also find every other
episode the show notes links from this
episode at for our blog.com that's fo u
rho u r VL og calm and just click on
podcast there's all sorts of other cool
stuff including my interactions when
people like Warren Buffett Mike Shinoda
Linkin Park the list goes on and on and
on and I would love your feedback let me
know what you thought of this show who
would like to hear on the show next and
any other thoughts really you can find
me at twitter @ @ t ferrus that's
twitter.com /tf ER Riss and on facebook
at facebook.com forward slash Tim
Ferriss with two R's and two S's until
next time thank you for listening
you